[Music]
you're listening to inside of you with
michael rosenbaum
i feel bloated ryan
i feel bloated you look great i feel
tired i'm jet lagged from australia it
was a great trip but holy
when you go when you fly that far when
you fly 15 hours
you're changing so many time zones you
get there your body's like f
off dude
and it says f off for a couple days and
then i had to change get another plane
to perth after sydney and then flying
home perth to sydney sydney to l.a to
like 20 hours
and i'm just like holy and i got to do
some interviews tomorrow i got to step
up man but was it magical
i wouldn't call it magical i would call
it a delight it was the people are a
delight i would move there we saw some
wonderful things i hung out with tom of
course tom welling my cohort from the
new podcast talkville oh
uh speaking about that folks a reminder
tom welling and i are doing a smallville
re-watch podcast it premieres in a
couple of weeks on wednesday july 13th
uh ryan tayas will be in that podcast
he'll be enjoying you'll be enjoying him
as well right ryan that's right i'm very
excited i'm very enjoyable you're you
are enjoyable subscribe wherever you get
your podcast or head over to
talkvillepodcast.com to learn more and
to give you a little taste of what we
got in store here's a little teaser for
our new show
talkville
hey guys i'm tom welling i used to play
clark kent on smallville i'm michael
rosenbaum i used to play lex luthor on
smallville join us every week as we go
back
way back i'm excited i know are you
can't wait join tom welling and michael
rosenbaum every week as they rewind
every episode of smallville and discuss
their experiences with friends fans and
co-stars talkville the ultimate
smallville podcast
it's going to be a lot of fun guys i
hope you guys subscribe
we have a bunch of handles and you can
follow us it's pretty much talkville at
talkville pod or talkville but you'll
find it just go online because i don't
have it with me right now
but uh
just
google it just google the freaking thing
it's gonna be a great show and you know
we're talking about smallville or
watching every episode to get me to
watch episodes and then talk about them
it's a big feat back to the inside of
you episode uh our guest today is tommy
flanagan
wonderful stories wonderful stories i
could just listen to him talk all day i
love that accent when he's speaking
and he tells us about you know the night
fight where he got his scar he tells us
about the new show uh what's it called
the powerbook four force powerbook for
four horse
which he adores how much he loves acting
and so much more but first we appreciate
it if you're here for tommy that you
give the podcast a chance and if you
like it you know subscribe you can
scribe uh these handles on
on on instagram twitter and facebook
they're at inside of you pod on twitter
at insiderviewpodcast on instagram and
facebook that is correct
we're very excited um hopefully you'll
subscribe to the podcast we're also on
youtube if you want to watch it you
might miss a couple of things i do with
my face orion does some reactions that
you might want to see not just here
uh you can find that on youtube we also
have a youtube youtube clips channel and
so much more also if you want to join
patreon the lovely patreons if you're a
patreon if you don't know what it is
patrons support the podcast they make it
happen so if you enjoy this podcast and
you want to give back a little it's easy
go to patreon pay t p p a t r e i told
you i'm [__] jet lagged sorry for the
f-bomb patreon p-a-t-r-e-o-n
inside of you become a patron i'll
message you back right afterwards um i
haven't been on the online for two weeks
but now i'm gonna start going back and
thanking people for joining and there's
so many perks and you get boxes for me
if you're a top tier and shout outs on
the podcast which you'll hear at the end
of the podcast
so um it's going to be pretty amazing
and also if you want to get any great
merch tons of awesome merch whether it's
smallville merch or inside emerge go to
the inside of you online store
um some pretty groovy stuff there and
the and you go to sunspin.com for any
band stuff if you want to also if you
want to um zoom with me
enough about that enough about me enough
about this and that
ryan are you good i'm all right are you
all right yeah because you've been
traveling i have been traveling are you
done traveling i'm gonna keep traveling
yeah aren't you going to ireland going
to ireland yeah good lord i know it
doesn't stop
i couldn't go because i uh obviously
this whole i went to metropolis illinois
came back for a day flew to australia
for two weeks just landed can't go back
to ireland i think i would collapse
it's just impossible and i have a con
although the con just got cancelled
just found out the con got cancelled
but uh i'm still going to palm springs
no no matter what anyway great so just
in time for summer you know what they
say two tears in a bucket mother
you know you said it i didn't let's just
do this let's get into tommy flanagan i
love this guy he's a friend he is uh
he's brilliant on this podcast i think
you're gonna really enjoy him and uh
let's just do it let's get inside of
tommy flanagan it's my point
[Music]
inside of you with michael rosenbaum was
not recorded in front of a live studio
audience yeah the guests always look
really good i always talk about this but
the guests always look better than me if
you're a handsome pastor problems come
on don't fight it
i'm telling you dude you embrace your
beauty embrace
see do you do you feel like everybody
when you do interviews first of all you
don't do interviews i don't do listen i
seriously i don't [__] do them and
when i do do them i want them to end
immediately
it's like i'll say two words and i'm
going to talk to you anymore leave me
alone why is that
i i it's always the same stories and but
when you called me i thought you know
the beautiful rose and blue it's going
to be a laugh
and bloom and i've heard good old
sparkles and i've heard your show and
it's so funny and it never feels like
you you're trying to flog something
you know what i mean i just want to talk
you just don't you just talk you get
inside of people
that's right get in there get right up
in there son do you get people ask you a
lot of times to do uh to do interviews
and things that you just say no
yes because your agent calls your
counsel your publicist college and says
they want you to do this no
i'm good i want to do a photo shoot no
i'm good and then the one then i'll
suddenly do one and they'll hate it i
don't know why i i
i like doing what we do i just don't
like all the right the [__] that
goes with it you know yeah well you were
saying like right when we got in here
and it was good to see because we met on
guardians of the galaxy too we met
before before that before that yeah yeah
that's right you know
a long time before yeah where did we
meet i don't remember
it's good
maybe i just thought i knew you because
when i saw you on guardians i thought
there's [__] rosin blue i'm going to
go talk to him i love him and then we
started chechon
outside we were having a smoke we call
them darts in in do you call them darts
and uh flags [__] yeah you can't flags
and it's cigarettes they don't go
[__] up your blouse about this it's
cigarettes it's
not do you still smoke no i quit
everything i've quit everything i'm the
most boring let me give you about a
world advice when it comes to alcohol
drugs and cigarettes and all these [__]
please do that do it when you're 50
spend those years that fly by
um
you know just making [__] money or
doing the thing that you love and then
when you turn 50 become a mad [__]
alcoholic junkie i think it's the way
forward wait you said when you heard 50
to become an alcoholic yeah i mean i'm
about to become 50. are you an alcoholic
yet no no well
i'm not smoking anymore right i'm not uh
you know
this is my sense this is the same my
rationale all right right right because
you
when you get to 15 if you've
rather just wasted all that time that i
wasted personally
like getting [__] high and drunk and
all the [__] we do
if i'd ask focus more when i first got
here
then you know i wouldn't have to do some
of the [__] that i've had to do over the
years you know and that'd be marvelous
and i could be i could be retired now
[__] my [__] mind
drunk high stoned every [__] day
they've been great but were you ever
reckless reckless
where it's like where it's like you got
a big speech the next morning yeah i
gotta act and you get just shit-faced
till two in the morning um i i'm gonna
say no
never [__] liar i don't know how
people do it i can't do it i'm just too
stressed you know what i know it gets me
hungover now i just found out easter
sugar
i had so much candy i woke up the next
day with a [__] hangover the raven
the raven crazy ass scotsman who fights
and drinks like a [__]
crazy man and and i had some too much
candy
easter and i had a hangover the next day
it's never again never again never again
was always i'd actually said that have
you ever like one time i got high
actually i got high once filming years
ago because i had very few lines that
day so i kind of smoked a little joint
washed
not a good idea i was so paranoid
why am i not doing it right am i am i
off am i off what's the matter
my your energy is kind of low you hit me
yeah i was paranoid it's horrible have
you done it too i've done that it's the
worst i did it doing macbeth when i
first started on on stage
how do you get stoned before you know oh
listen there's a story behind it
we've been rehearsing rehearsing
rehearsing and you know it was the first
week we got the first week under our
belt
the six theater i think it was in
glasgow or or whatever the [__] in
glasgow
so when a weekend and my friend shows up
in my apartment and he says oh i just
get this amazing weed it's called skunk
and i thought oh you know i'll try
something this is a long time ago kids
and i said i'll try something up it's 12
o'clock by seven o'clock cutting up i'll
be fine
no
i smoked some of that one o'clock i'm
still at my mind two o'clock three
o'clock four o'clock now you're getting
caught you're getting paid now i'm
breaking out even more because it's
getting closer to the curtain and i'm
just freaked out my mind
and um
then all of a sudden i'm on the stage
macbeth the dude
shakespeare's flying and you're still
high i'm high in my [__] mind i
couldn't i can't i want to where am i
and then macbeth turns to me
who wait is that the door or some [__]
who are you playing i was playing
seating mentee
i played like four different cards oh
god oh lord yeah try that one so i'm
playing all these mad crazy characters
and then he says who's who knocketh on
the door which is not shakespeare
and that's not i don't know what it was
i i he says to me who's not going to do
it nicely there's a couple of guys at
the door
which is definitely not shakespeare
and it shakes me shakespeare fans sit in
the audience and they turn the pages you
see them with the books and
i can hear that that's not what he i
said it's called guys at the door anyway
boring story but that's why you
shouldn't smoke marijuana kids did uh
robert carlisle who got you into acting
uh into
stage and stuff did he did he call you
out after do you say were you high did
he say anything to you didn't you get
any left probably do you have any on you
yeah bobby uh bobby kelley i love that
kid that kid you guys still talk oh yeah
yeah yeah we had a little uh a little um
gap and and her love
but uh yeah he's he's fantastic i always
found that to be just an interesting
story because your life would have been
completely different right
my life was crazy i i was working as a
dj a dg what kind of music are you
playing and what year is it bring me
back all right i'm 21 years old i'm in
greece i was djing a little bit in
glasgow then i get i get offered this
job in greece
and i think perfect timing so you're a
good dj to get offered things and like
yeah well i think the ghetto like me the
girl who who was getting married to the
greek guy who owned the bar restaurant
play club that i was djing and son
santorini santorini
that's an island
rafty that's what it was
anyway i'd get there in the nick of time
because i had warrants out for my arrest
so i thought it was tightly skipped town
anyway so it was very handy so i went
there for six months
not for anything bad just silly stuff
and i get there and then after six
months i come back to glasgow because i
was in love with this girl at the time
which i wasn't five minutes off the
train i thought what the hell am i doing
back here
and then i started djing there and the
whole scene had changed to i see and
house music and all that kind of stuff
so i had to throw all my records away
and then start again
so then i was now in the rave scene
which just cropped up everywhere you
fight in a warehouse an old barn
and you've put flyers out and thousands
of people you know and they will come
what kind of music were you playing
before the rave vulva it was kind of
easy clubby [__] like who was your
favorite bands back then who were you
listening to
i would see psychedelic force icker the
body man yeah
were you a smith's fan smash
kenny i know i'm honestly always bugged
and [__] but he bugs me now i love
morrissey but now he bugs me yeah and
yeah i i used to love the smurfs
attached but the there
the the the yes that was always a good
one for crowd pleaser that was always
it's just hard to imagine you as a dj
because now i look at you you're fun
loving but i mean but you play these
dark characters we just were talking
about this right before we started
talking on the show but you were like
you want to do something funny and you
you might do something with reno 9-1-1
that's possible right no well
let's keep that on the routes but yeah
hopefully i would speak to katie
yesterday and uh yeah i'd love should we
not mention that should i bleep that out
i don't know it's all good i'm sure yeah
it's fine but you might you might do
something i didn't say you're doing
something
i'm i'm gonna do i'm doing the power
thing let me finish my little story my
little joke [__] your story up i was
saying no no no no no no no no i just i
just i i have i i just thought about how
bobby carell came at the conversation
the transition sorry
inside of you is brought to you by
freedom grooming why wasn't this around
when i was doing smallville shaving my
head every day ryan man it really should
have been huh i keep hearing your
stories i could have been their
spokesman then yeah i could have been
the bald guy on there
lex luthor talking about
freedom grooming at freedom grooming we
make the flex series electric shaver
which is uniquely designed to flex and
contour to the curve of your head for a
smoother faster and safer shave without
the risk of nicks cuts irritation or
ingrown hairs
while our grooming products work
anywhere in the body our strongest
demographic is with our bald community
and our advertising speaks with them we
are proudly supporting our hair free
customers and their journey to bald hood
i'll tell you what they were there were
times when i uh the makeup artist would
nick my head with a regular straight
straight edge razor or even a yeah man
it was just and man where was freedom
grooming then
this is a great product this is a great
product for folks that just
are want want to have make their lives
easier get the smoothest shave of your
life flexible blades contour to the
shape of your head for a baby smooth
shave every time
shave 50 percent more hair in a single
stroke compared to traditional razors
expect shave times of two to three
minutes and not 10 to 15. never cut
yourself shaving the flex series
safeguard technology means no nicks no
ingrown hairs no problems and the flex
series waterproof design means that you
can shave in the shower with or without
shaving cream shave wet or dry since
even the sharpest blades dull with use
freedom created the close shave plan
with the close shave plan you'll never
run out of fresh sharp blades delivered
to your door every six weeks with free
shipping all active close shave plan
members are upgraded in a lifetime
warranty and it's completely
customizable adjust skip or cancel your
plan
anytime we have over ten thousand five
star reviews so if you want 20 off go to
freedomgrooming.com
inside that's freedomgrooming.com
inside
inside of you is brought to you by magic
spoon i swear to you ryan i just have my
friend joe over here we're talking
packing merch box [__] merch [__]
merch we're packing merch boxes up here
packing the boxes up for my all my
patrons my lovely patrons um
and he goes who are your sponsors these
days and i go well i still i'm with so
and so and uh magic spoon oh you said
dude i love magic spoon you're still
with them i'm like yeah well they're
still with me he's like i really really
love that cereal it's really good
and that's coming from an adult guys
because we were told as kids that you
know we were it was okay to eat cereal
tons of sugar sugar sugar sugar but then
as we get
adulthood everybody kind of looked down
on us if we had cereal it's like uh
that's really bad for you you must be
you're eating poorly
but with magic spoon it's different
isn't it
magic spoon is uh
i mean you can enjoy cereal enjoy that
feeling of nostalgia and childhood with
a cereal that is just better for you um
let's talk about that zero grams of
sugar 13 to 14 grams of protein only
five four or five net grams of carbs in
each serving it's low carb it's keto
friendly it's gluten free it's grain
free soy free and only 140 calories a
serving build your own box with a huge
variety of appealing flavors ryan you
got the classics like cocoa fruity
frosted and peanut butter love peanut
butter the cult faves blueberry muffin
maple waffle and honey nut
and the indulgent ones cookies and cream
and cinnamon roll oh doesn't that just
sound great yeah you know magic spoon is
also packed with protein and a great
healthy snack for just about anyone
whether it's after a workout during a
hike or at midnight when the cravings
strike there's flavor for everyone from
the richest chocolate to the sweetest
honey nut go to
magicspoon.com
iou to grab a custom bundle of cereal
and try the magic for yourself seriously
try it for yourself because you will not
be disappointed be sure to use our promo
code iou at checkout to save five
dollars off your order and magic spoon
is so confident in their product it's
backed with a hundred percent happiness
guarantee if you don't like it for any
reason they refund your money no
questions asked i don't know what you're
doing if somebody offered me something
pretty much for free
i would try it that's who i am remember
get your next delicious bowl of
guilt-free cereal at magicspoon.com
iou and use the code iou to save five
dollars off
thank you magic spoon for sponsoring
this episode
sorry and then the transition from djing
and then i dj until i was like 24 25 and
then uh i went to a knife fight without
a knife and i ended up looking like this
and they put holes in me
how how close were you to death dead
deal came they got me to the hospital i
was i'd play that how many times do they
stab you i guess i'll leave that for my
memoirs those little beautiful details
for your memoirs
but you had no idea that these they just
attacked you no i i i yeah yeah i can't
mouth in them no they they told me
they'd [__] up my brother
we've done your brother was the comment
and that in glasgow means he's done he's
he's over and i lost my [__]
and i slapped some [__] and i said
i'll take all you guys outside and i
went outside like
and i waited for them like a [__]
idiot and i knew they they were sold up
but anyway they came out those fire eggs
and i went
and then
fired by yourself by myself with my
trusty heineken bottle which was not
very handy jesus christ
stop stop stop
and you did you honestly when you close
your eyes i'm dead now this is my the
end of my life i was so enraged i
remember that i remember the pain of the
knife going in if that hurt you could
feel it you weren't in shock it hurt
just you your body just buckles
and you just feel out everything coming
out you
and then he tried to stab me twice and i
grabbed the blade and it cut through my
there all the way through here
i'm punching it in my thumb
and then the other guy was
it was just ripped scott anyway i got my
back against the wall kept kicking and
then
i started walking
and then anyway i i survived they got me
the whole like they survived the slogan
goes on and on right but they got me
there
and they're nick italian whatever
brought me back to life and then uh
bobby kalell when i go to hospital bobby
kept seeing me and he said tommy
why
why you keep doing this crazy world
you're in why don't you try
joining my theater company
come and join rain how old are you 25
just 25.
and i never thought about acting in my
life not for one second i'd always loved
movies you know i mean what did you love
what what what inspired you what did you
who what actor did you know the most
bizarre thing was was uh was mad max
with mel mel gibson mad max
mad max was a badass who's a badass
[__] and then
my first movie is braveheart with mel
gibson it was one of those bizarre ones
so i did this with bobby for a couple of
years braveheart comes to town
patsy pollock casting director sees a
little bit of meow she comes to the
theater and goes
get right heaven wrapped and cleaned and
brought around some hell tomorrow so i
go and see mel and the rest is um
what are your what are your parents
thinking when you said yeah i've decided
not to dj i had this revelation i almost
died carlisle comes in and says i should
be an actor what are your what's your
mom thinking because i know your
thoughts mama what did mom say well my
mom um
she was uh
so
relieved i think because i mean glasgow
is a tough tough town and she's just
seen her son
on his deathbed
brought back to life with his face open
and you know she was horrified yeah and
she i remember she came to visit me in
the hospital this is so [__]
depressing
no this is i mean this is real [__] this
is like well it's real [__] and but she
came to see me in hospital and i
remember lying there it was day one and
they've got me the morphine thing dude
here's my sound effect because i was a
morphine pump before that's a very fella
that's so good so much fun don't do it
kids don't do it get damaged first then
fentanyl fentanyl is what you want no
kidding stay away from all this here we
go
all that [__] that's all [__] but
she saw you there she saw me there i
remember thinking
oh my god why why is she being so strong
why i mean i'm not strong i thought she
doesn't see me care
they were thinking i can't be that bad
because i hadn't seen myself obviously
right it can't be that bad and she's
tucking the bed and there's friends all
around me i've got like a million
flowers i look like [__] liberace
with the amount of roses i've got
so my mom's
then she leaves and then years later
months later years later let's say
my friend say to me you know when your
mom left like she collapsed in the
elevator
so she was being so strong for me you
know wow so when i
finally stepped onto the birds
and she came to see me and uh i mean she
knew i was shy at first but because she
knew it was potential
and she always always tell me yeah
you're pretty good son pretty good son
pretty good son and then always
supportive always really supportive did
all your siblings come to see the plays
yeah it was kinda
kinda what does that mean
well they slept through it it's probably
yeah they you know
under your ass get there or you got
beaten but now the uh they would i've
got two brothers and two sisters and
they would kind of show up occasionally
to my
performances but they supported you they
all support me thursday what was the
first play you did at conquest of the
south pole it was called by
my memory but a big role
no it was just uh just to get you going
just just to get me the feel of the
stage were you nervous on stage
terrifying right and i remember sat in
this oil drum and when i s at the
backstage i never done it in rehearsal
and i'm so everyone's on stage at the
opening the curtain goes up everyone's
on stage and it's a kind of like
desolate [__]
ravaged place and i'm on this oil drum
and when i sit on it the metal goes down
you know depresses sort of thing and i
think oh my god i stand up this thing's
going to go dying behind me
and sure is [__] sugar nuts
i've got it's my cue and i go off this
oil drum and boing right behind me and
every head
the main actor sandy morton it was and i
see my line
and then i run off stage and i remember
standing backstage going
shutting myself but you from that moment
you still had like you wanted it you
wanted to be better you wanted to you
found something that you just it scared
the [__] out of you but it was a good
fear yeah it was a good fear to feel
that i liked and i wanted to pursue it
and i wanted to be the best i could on
it did you need to hear affirmation did
you need to hear who was it that
constantly said hey you got something
there's something here you're good good
job who just glasgow is great for that
because they never give you that it's a
great confirmation it's like they get
that
that was all right
that's it and that's pure love that's
love that's all right i get that you
know what you get you want kid you got
presents i'll give you that
and then it's like all right
i'm doing something because they'll tell
you they're [__] they're a tough
audience and a tough you know so when
did you think i'm [__] i'm good i'm
good i still do i'm still [__] i'm
still that guy runs off the stage
kidding me
i don't think that ever goes away does
it do you still think you know when you
do stuff you're like
[__] i hope that's good yeah yeah you
have confidence or do you hide it do you
think that you you play tough guys a lot
of times you have to have this
confidence do you think it's like you
have to have this false bravado do you
think that you go into it
confidently or do you kind of like just
say i hope they buy that i hope i look
tough enough i don't i go on it with uh
with a lot of history
growing up where i grew up i i i just
think a certain people that i grew up
with
or
who i knew back in the day
and
i remember the fear when you meet some
people you've been i've never been in a
room with certain people who wouldn't
say a single word
but their silence was the most
terrifying thing
and then the only time they'd ever
speak up in conversation if violence was
mentioned oh yeah i remember the time
i cut off uh wally's
fingers and stuck up his nose and put
him in his ears you know something weird
yeah but you remembered certain people
from i remember i always
draw on people from the past
and uh
yeah because you know i grew up in tough
places but i was never you know i i you
know i could throw my hands a bit with
all that nonsense but but it's all
nonsense do you think after you you like
you face death like you did like you're
on your deathbed
does that make you i mean it probably
does probably a stupid question but does
it make you stronger do you feel like
i'm not scared of anybody now i'm not
scared of anything because i've been so
close you know what you know what it
makes you it makes you
it makes you
it makes you recognize fear
and when i grew up you never show fear
to show fear is to show weakness
what it made me do was
it's okay
to be afraid
it's okay to be afraid that you just
nearly died but it hands us five [__]
psychopaths with knives it's okay to be
afraid of that
and that took me a minute and when i
i've never had this conversation before
and when i had that moment of it was a
revelation what do you want to call it
um
it cleared the way for me and
it's okay it's okay you can be afraid
it's okay
it was a relief it was such a relief and
then i could take anything on because
it's okay and then if you failed it's
okay you [__] feel
just keep going you just go like you
know
and now a word from our sponsor
better help better help has been with me
been with us on this podcast for quite
some time i think they believe in the
podcast and it's obviously that we
believe in them uh we both use
betterhelp uh
you you can i could speak to you right
now especially yeah i can vouch for it
yeah you can i've seen your whole
disposition change from the time you
started therapy oh really until now
absolutely in fact when you talk about
therapy you smile you're kind of like
it's just it's an outlet for you isn't
it that's good to know yeah i just feel
a change there's a good change um you
know this is a good question how well
would you take care of your car if you
had to keep the same one your entire
life
well that's how our brains work so why
don't we treat them that way
how we take care of our minds affects
how we experience life so it is
important to invest time and care into
keeping them healthy and there are
plenty of ways to support a healthy
brain learning a new language taking
power naps i love that but there's also
better help online therapy ryan you were
stressed up bottled up all these things
were you know kind of just like dragging
you down a little bit and then you said
i'm gonna try this and i was surprised i
was like you know being that they were a
sponsor i didn't assume you'd be like
yeah i'm going to jump on this one
and you did and and uh what can you say
well it helped for sure uh
i mean you're still in it i'm still in
it yeah i found a good therapist uh
and she's been really helpful and it's
been really really good i love that i
yes and if if you can tell that my
disposition has changed then i think
that's a good sign yeah you just seem
like you're happier to be here
you're happier to you're just more
present i mean not that you weren't
present but uh i take it man i dig it i
dig it i'm glad i'm glad it's helping
better help is online therapy that
offers video phone and even chat only
therapy sessions so you don't have to
see anyone on camera if you don't want
to i like to see people but you don't
have to it's much more affordable than
in-person therapy i could vouch for that
it is way way more affordable than that
and you can be matched with a therapist
in under 48 hours our listeners here at
inside of you get ten percent off their
first month at betterhelp.com
inside that's betterhelp.com
inside if something's bothering you if
you've got a lot in your mind if you're
bottling it all up i strongly suggest
you give better help online therapy a
chance they really help
inside of you is brought to you by
shopify what i would not do what i
wouldn't do
without shopify shopify
my shopify account for my podcast has
truly truly grown and it's something
that scared me having some website to
handle all the merch and all the stuff
and then i realized shopify is so easy
to use
uh it's surprisingly easy guys if i can
do this i don't read directions i i
i i don't do things well you you know
this if you listen to the podcast
having shopify
is
is like i don't know what i would do
without them that's honest to god i have
a shopify account you guys go there it's
the inside of you online store um and
it's grown exponentially shopify gives
entrepreneurs the resources once
reserved for big businesses so upstarts
startups and established businesses
alike can sell everywhere synchronize
online and in-person sales and
effortlessly stay informed scaling your
business is a journey of endless
possibility believe me i think i started
selling a t-shirt when this thing
started
now i'm selling lunch boxes and
scripts and
signed mugs and tumblers and hats and
the list goes on uh this is uh and you
what's great is you could see how well
you're doing what's your top item that's
selling how much you're making this
month what items aren't selling well how
many you have left of this item it's so
easy it's so right there in front of you
that anyone can do this so if you're if
you're looking to to sell stuff i don't
know how you don't try shopify i don't
know that there is anybody else but
shopify is there ryan
not that i know of so hey shopify i
think you're the only way to go like
mine shopify powers millions of
businesses from first sale to full scale
reach customers online and across social
networks with an ever-growing suite of
channel integrations and apps including
facebook instagram tick tock pinterest
and more gain insights as you grow with
detailed reporting of conversion rates
profit margins and beyond more than a
store shopify grows with you this is
possibility powered by shopify go to
shopify.com
inside all lower case at shopify.com
inside all lowercase for a free 14-day
trial and get full access to shopify's
entire suite of features grow your
business with shopify today go to
shopify.com
inside right now shopify.com
inside
yeah do you uh would you nowadays walk
away from a fight if somebody picked a
fight with you would you walk away if
somebody told you to [__] off i probably
wouldn't you'd probably fight oh i no
god damn i mean we're we're getting old
to the point where when i if
i would much prefer to walk away but i i
do have a mouth on at times i do have a
mouth does it still happen every once in
a while if somebody says something to
you you know you cannot live in a bubble
now you know i live in [__] you know
you know there and so you know there's
not really any malibu tough guys kicking
around so
i'm a safe zone at the moment
but um
no i don't think so there's no point
there's just no point it's just i i'm
not about the hate and revenge thing
anymore it's just
you know i it screwed me up for a lot of
years
you know after this as well i mean i
came here
in 90s i did braveheart and mel said you
just come to california meet some people
so so he liked you he took you under his
wing in a while i was only supposed to
be on braveheart for two weeks this
bridegroom didn't have a [__] name
the bridegroom
and i was supposed to get killed and
because you're everywhere in that movie
yeah he then mel said no no
we're keeping him
so i was four weeks in scotland and i
thought then they were moving to ireland
for five months so i'm like so what the
[__] so i've got to production see so
what am i doing here i was only supposed
to be for two weeks now it's four now
you guys are going to ireland i'm
curious am i going with you hold on a
second i checked the script he's
flipping through the script to get to
scene 200 and something
oh no you're here taught me oh okay
great
six months
six months i was on that movie six
months was it one of the best moments
you're like the
best well what about it was so great hey
it was your first movie my first movie
and it was it won six oscars
and i mean
you knew it was an epic i'm sitting on
the battlefield with
mel gibson's brother donal
without the d
dorm without
i'd so he tells that story he told his
name was donald without the d and the
girl said oh arnold
no donal without that never mind
but i'm sitting on this hell with donal
without the d
and uh
he i'm just certainly going to watch
this battle scenes i mean it was no seat
it was very very little cgi back then
and it's just thousands of extras it's
the irish army the irish volunteer army
i want to kill people oh i'm going to
kill you right right
and just charging each other to the
point where mel was like you know what
guys it's a [__] movie we don't want
anyone to die so
but just watching it was just this epic
thing he just knew it was going to be
huge but it's got to be tough going from
one of the best movies ever made to then
continuing your career because usually
it's like you do a shitty movie i did
this piece of [__] followed by another
piece of [__] followed by hey you were
good in that piece of [__] yeah and then
we oh that's a good one and there's
another
but to go from you were in the
one of the best movies ever made and
then what was the next thing you did the
next thing was
the saint well that was good
another good one the the game another
good one well little parts but you know
it was still something
and then
i think it was gladiator was next jesus
which is another one i was supposed to
be on for
a short period then russell russell
tells the story then russell and ridley
had the conversation oh let's keep this
kid around why is it what is it about
you it's my fabulous talent and [__]
what do you think mel thought when he
met you are you just i mean maybe what i
see is just a really likable fun guy to
have around who's actually tout really
talented yeah plus i think
you know we live in such a
we work in such an insecure
[__] business i mean i mean i mean my
god if you want to become an actor then
good luck stick with that but it's so
[__] so
and all these other things yeah
but um but what is it they maybe you
think that they had a liking to you that
they felt better when you were on set
they liked having you around i don't
know really i don't know are you friends
with him to this day i am yeah i still
talk with russell i still talk with
melvis um readily i've got tons of love
for
he's just you talk to ridley i was
brought to italy in a while now i have
to say you know a long time since i
spoke to ridley but i'd love the money
death he's he's great but what was it
like like a movie like gladiator again
intense it was incredible my my first
day i is
well i get to malta and
i walk on a
huge
huge set it's like rome they built
[__] rome and those hyenas and
giraffes and tigers and lions and all
coming parading down the streets huge
big cranes swooping in and okay tommy we
need you
and remember i didn't have any training
i thought you did some theater i did
this in theater there's a video that's
training
which was great for the acting thing but
as far as filming went right i just i
just sat there and watched you know i
would hang out at video village and
watch what's up we'll start doing it ask
questions maybe that's what was so great
maybe the fact that you weren't so aware
so aware of yourself that you could be
more free and you could and almost
theatrically in a lot of ways i never
never thought about that i never saw it
as a career i always waited for it i was
always thinking okay this is my last
moment ever
no not like in a depressed way i just
thought okay this is fun
let's see where it goes and it just kept
going and going and going is that still
how you feel at this point you finally
go ahead no no that's my job now that's
just uh this is what how long did it
take before you said okay
i'm an actor because it took me quite a
while before i i thought that oh god it
takes so long doesn't it does take a
long time because you're working with
these amazing people and you think i
can't do it yeah and you think but but
you know what
you just have to accept this is what i
do and this is it took me a long time
too many years
i would say god
probably even after braveheart i was
still floundering trying to figure out
what the hell i'm doing really you
weren't sure if you were yeah i wasn't
sure but i think i also i wasn't um
i didn't want to ask anyone i just
assumed they all assumed that i knew
what i was doing but i didn't have a
[__] clue so you're like why did they
keep casting me why did it keep giving
me i don't know what i'm doing here do
you watch yourself no
never no well i said
the show i'm doing right now is power
for force power for force on stars on
stars it's the 50 cent courtney camp
um
power universe you watch that
i just did we just finished the first
season and i love joseph zakora honestly
he's one of the best if not the
actor i've ever worked with maybe the
best maybe very close to it wow
yeah he's [__] bro i'm telling you
joseph sakura
is one of the most
underestimated actors of our time this
guy he's just so good
another guy michael soccer who's also
brilliant anyway they elevate the verse
and to watch these guys i love it and i
want to be and i like to play in that
arena i want it come on let's let's go
for it and i love it now it makes you
better doesn't it makes you it's like
when you're playing you know i play pick
up sports like i'll play pick up hockey
and if i'm out there with a bunch of
other old guys like me
you know i'm just i don't
but when there's great players playing
against you like sometimes the pr some
pros play on their off season it
elevates you it makes you want to be
better it excites you slightly you know
it does it's just exciting i love it do
you still honest to god don't lie to me
do you get nervous i get terrified you
still get nervous when you ask yes yes
yes yes every time every time bro not
every take but usually
once once when some end once a minute
i'm fine but just that walk from the
trailer to the [__] stage
then get that first line out especially
that first day
oh my god
yeah why is it i don't maybe it's you
want everybody to go okay he's here for
a reason the director's like yeah
tommy's here
he's good everybody's good like okay now
i can stop being so afraid and you get
that and that's wonderful but at the
same time they're just saying that it's
so it's crazy
it's such a mind [__] it's our main
focus who runs lines with you oh god
that was a problem last season i was um
the covered bubble so it was really hot
i was facetiming my wife in running
lines and stuff really which doesn't
really work you need to have someone in
the room you can throw a script at or
screamer
you know as in carrick some sort of
thing but it was just to memorize lines
just to memorize the lines just to get
them in there but it wasn't for some
reason it wasn't sticking with me you
know we were talking before we didn't
really elaborate on this but you want
you want to do more comedy
call me the other yeah come on what do
you want to do like what would you
you're one of the money's funniest money
is i'm not that you've got the money you
are the money yeah that's just why this
is that here we go back to not knowing
where we are and how good we are you're
[__] hilarious the reason i'm doing
this show is because you're so [__]
cool but we're getting deep
we got some deep [__] right up and
straight up inside just saying
ryan ryan loves this
guy's ryan's over there yeah he's not on
camera what no what you're enjoying this
i'm enjoying this yeah doesn't have fun
he's got such a great personality
it's it's great it is you've got you
know you just you can you can tell
stories that's what i like is you can
tell stories and when you tell them i'm
there right i'm there see my my my great
grandfather charlie riley was a merchant
seaman
nothing to do with sperm traveling the
oceans he [__]
emerson semen and he uh
he lived he was 96 years old usual story
he smoked cigarettes every day drag
whiskey every day didn't it
but he because he traveled the world
when he kind of retired in his life
he would go from town to town in ireland
and he would tell stories in different
bars and everyone would buy him drinks
and he would sit and tell his tales i
was in hong kong i was here
you know just a storyteller so maybe not
so that's how you get it that's where
you get us where the shenanigans comes
from i don't know maybe maybe so when
we're talking like what like who would
you like to work with like a judd apatow
movie like uh like a jim carrey movie a
will ferrell movie
would you do something like that all
those guys were saying yeah adam sandler
asked you to do a movie would you do it
sure absolutely you do something crazy
and stupid do something nuts i mean why
not because i mean i know i get nervous
and stuff but i think that's another
motivator motivate and another another
barrier to kick downs that i can go out
there and just be a goofy [__] right
and which is great that's right just to
lose yourself and be stupid and then if
it works it works if it doesn't then it
gives a [__] yeah you know i mean end of
the day it's not [__] saving
curing cancer or any [__] it's just
having a giggle could you do anything
else do you think from no if it wasn't
acting no is there anything else you
could do besides dj you can go back to
the youtube back to djing maybe some
armed robbery or uh
no
um i don't i don't know i think uh
this is what this is what i do this is a
this is uh you couldn't imagine you're
producing obviously but uh do you have
do you have to work do you feel like you
have to constantly be busy constantly
filming or you'll go crazy i do yeah you
do
is that is that a healthy thing i don't
think so because i mean i i've done some
shite
i mean i i mean let's face it i've had
we've all done it well you know you have
to it's just something how do you but
how do you
if you're doing shite you know it's
shite
but yeah i don't believe it at the time
at the time i have so much love for what
i do
and i never i never i've never call it
and that's because that's ridiculous but
i'll go there and give it a 100
and you just hope that
everything falls into place and yeah so
have you ever done shite and knew it was
shite while you're filming the shite oh
god
[Laughter]
the shake trail the shade trail these
shades i know uh
yeah i have [__] yeah oh god it's not a
good feeling but you have to kind of
convince yourself it's all good or you
don't trust the director oh when he go
there's a couple of directions i could
have kicked up and doing the [__] set
yeah are you just like i was in fact i
did chase what a certain director one
time really yeah what happened oh he
annoyed me
what what did he do it was like i had to
kick this door open
and it was quite a big feature this
thing pretty big and uh i i i just
kicked this door open
and it was set a certain way that the
door handle should fly off and i had to
kick it a certain way and whatever
[__]
and i kicked her and the next minute
[__] it's already getting my nerves
this guy and um
that's oh god damn it son of a [__]
[__] and throws his little monitor down
and i went
and i went chasing after him around the
set you chased they had to stop you i
chased him there can i stop me saying
tommy told me come on he's just it's
just been is he scared
well he
yeah he left the building rapidly boom
do you know that happened to me once
where uh i mean i don't think i'm gonna
connect with a guy he's gonna interrupt
you but i wouldn't have i just wanted to
get his face and say you little shite
you told me to do it this week and this
is the first time we've done blah blah
blah right right right but he was and
you're being a little baby about it and
you're being a baby and i'm and i do see
my body and then he embarrasses you in
front of the crew it's like [__]
that's what it was
i was embarrassed once in front of the
crew and it had nothing to do with me
the guy was upset because he was late he
was behind and he just looked at me and
goes you're [__] me right now you're
[__] my day oh and he was he was so
if he was right i would have said sorry
sorry my bad but he was so wrong that i
was enraged i remember the take
the id goes rosie we're shooting we're
shooting now rolling rolling rolling
it's a big crane shot and it comes up to
me and it passes so and so uh this girl
and comes to me and i go [__] it and i
jump right i mean that was my it wasn't
my line obviously i just go [__] it and
i just bee-lined and they stopped me i
go don't you ever [__] i lost it yeah
and
and uh he eventually came to the trailer
and i go look man
you can never [__] talk to someone
like that again no you can't do that and
you were wrong yeah you know i remember
uh that
tom arnold you know tom arnold of course
tom was on we had tom doing a lot of
stuff sons of anarchy yeah
yeah so he was working with
schwarzenegger on uh
night what was that movie with uh what's
her name
jamie the curtis
true true two lies he was doing true
lies
and james cameron comes up to
schwarzenegger in the same fashion and
says
you are [__] me something like that
you're [__] me you are [__] me
right now because he's laid on set
and oh he walks away and tom goes hey
buddy
hey buddy i can't believe you let him
talk to you like that why don't you kick
his ass because because he was right
and that's what that's what it was
when the director's right but when he's
wrong yeah you have to you have to kind
of stand up for yourself and you know
and it's
whatever
this director in particular was was very
wrong that day yeah and he did embarrass
me in front of people did he apologize
no we never spoke everything was
communicated after that for how long for
the whole [__] shoot how long after
how long was that a month laughter a
month left was that uncomfortable no i i
didn't like him anyway so it was good
for me did you just get me what did you
want okay done
and the movie wasn't didn't turn out
well the movie was [__] were you good at
least no i've never seen that to be
honest maybe it's not [__] maybe no cat
must be [__] then we've done it yeah you
don't want it i've never seen it
by the way you have you still have a lot
of hair left i've got beautiful hair you
have good hair i mean
you know what's funny is i just went to
the the hairstylist the hairdryer the
the hair cutter the barber
it's gonna be bob [__] it's been a long
pandemic it's been a long long time
my guy he's fantastic nathan i love you
if you're listening he was looking and
he just says you know you have just this
little area that's thinning and it's
just you know [__] you nathan flex that
nathan no he just says honestly all you
do is get the foam rogaine or whatever
you use
hymns
and you just like put a little foam in
it every day
and let it and that's it just a little
dot right here
and it kind of bothered me not him
because he was honest and it was like
he's helping me but i'm about to turn 50
and i thought of course
now i'm going to start losing my hair
now it's going to all start falling
apart
because you're 56. i'm 56.
how are your 50s be honest because
you're paying any uh well you know what
if life begins in your 50s you you throw
so much [__] so much clutter is going on
up here
that you can finally say get the [__]
away from me
and just become 50. and there's nothing
it's cool but also all those aches
whether sports aches and pains or from
[__]
street fighting or whatever the hell you
did in your previous lives uh they all
come back every lump bump sprain and
strain comes back to say hi did you
forget everybody hey look at your knees
elbows fingers everything [__] thing
yeah
but the care
was because of covid
i
2020 i didn't leave my property not once
not one day all the way from september
then in the shot bringing down a march
the september to march was was my idea
of correct i want to spend some time
with my baby daughter
how old is your daughter now she's
turned 10 10. she's incredible does she
want to be an actress
she wants to save every animal on the
planet i love it my place is called
flannigan's ark we have so many [__]
animals how many animals do you have we
have five horses a donkey a mule a
miniature we have i don't know how many
chickens we have four dogs a parrot a
cat
a potter what i want a parrot a parrot
how you potter i'm a pilot it's my
american parrot
it's a parrot
apparently
so yeah so flannigan's ark and there's
more incoming i believe so
is it because of your daughter
but i love animals as well i have to
admit but you do but my daughter's just
she's crazy for animals
she's got an amazing sense of humor yeah
you know she's uh like i bought that i'm
working out right now for for season two
of power four force power four kid force
with tommy flanagan
and walter
and i bought this little bucket hat
you know for when i'm cycling to keep
the sun off they'll
mean right
and face and like i picked my daughter
up from school said daddy why did you go
to the car wearing that hat i said i was
working now honey
please don't wear the hat ever again
when you come to my school
and then she tried i was like no no no i
just i was sleeping in it i don't take
off we're having dinner everywhere we
went i had this [__] hat and i just
wouldn't take it off driving her crazy
and she kept trying to pull it off and
do it
and then she tried to do the reverse
psychology on me you know what actually
it's really cool on you daddy it's super
cool you should wear that all the time
no i'm like no no no no i've done that
do you feel like uh with you know
being married having a ten-year-old
daughter do you feel like now your age
you're thinking
i'd like to just kind of work in la if
possible unless it's something that i
can't miss up i mean
do you or you're like [__] i'll go
anywhere no no no i can't i it's not
[__] i'll go those days are over since
my daughter was born i just want to be
home home as much i want to work as
close to homeless poor i mean i mean i'm
only in chicago i'll be in chicago for
the next while right
maybe four or five years whatever
as long as the show goes and it will go
because it's great but um
but that's that's quite an easy one but
i would love to work you know i had the
luxury of sons of anarchy for seven
years when my daughter was first born so
yeah i go to work in the morning i could
come home at night which was fantastic
are you still close with those guys some
sons of americans yeah that's
a friendship they'll stay you know
that's not going anywhere i saw charlie
not long ago i see boone a lot i see kim
i see theo yeah we always bump into the
crowman perlman or the pair i love the
pearl was he fun to work with he's the
best he's such a sweetheart and he's so
he's such a beautiful human being and
i love his politics and he's so eloquent
i mean
he's just he's just he's just a
beautiful man you ever work with any
actors or you're just like i can't wait
till this [__] ends i can't stand
this [__] woman or man or whoever
oh god without saying we need to start
naming names though i think we just
start i think we just start naming
[__] should we just call them
out i don't think so
i mean for you you'll probably here's
what i don't give a [__] you won't give
a [__] you'll say it and then you call
me you know rosie [__] we probably
should bleep it no uh i have
oh [__] this one guy oh
god how bad was he and what made him bad
to work with but
because he was he was so he's so
he's so full of himself for a start and
the most talentless [__] actor
i've ever seen in my life and yet he's
huge
he's huge
and he makes so much [__] money and
he does all these [__] non-stop
movies and it's just
it's agonizing and i think good luck to
you son i'm happy you have a career but
you are a terrible [__] human being
the one i met anyway what was what was
it that makes up some of the horrible
things the way he treated the crew
exactly were [__]
peasants peasants or some [__] you know
and it was just just
gold me and i just i had to pull him up
and say you know what
you don't speak to other human beings
like that he's just [__] doing
and what do you say to you oh i was just
joking tommy i was just joking you know
who you are [__] you were just
joking so that was it you had to work
with him for a while i had the whole
movie
this was like day two or something
and it was [__] nowhere but anyway
that was all right we we figured
yeah i've had to work with people
there's been a few that i just like i
just i just feel like oh
i can't
they care just so much about themselves
why i don't know it's just like it's
about only about them
it's they're manipulative i've had that
and you just have to you have to just
somehow you have to come together as a
little community or a family whatever
you want to call it because it because
it's there on the screen when it's all
said and done there it is on the screen
you see the connection to chemistry
whatever you want to call it and
yeah you have to every single person has
to be equal you want to say the name so
badly i want to i won't really really
want to i won't let you i know thank you
rosie yeah
um this is called [__] talking [__] with
tommy
these are from fans these are my patrons
talking this time
it should be [__] talking
talking about
you [__] he speaks fluent
talking with tommy
talking with tommy flanagan and this is
from my lovable patrons my patrons they
give back to the podcast in many ways
page patreon.com inside of you thanks
for the support we love you these are
the questions and then they could be
fast however you want to rapid fire
let's go
uh david h says holy cow you are truly
an icon
what character have you played that you
would say is most like you if any
if any the character i'm playing right
now is there but the grace of god go i
power four power four force walter flynn
walter flynn walter flynn stars
fun stars get your stars
with joseph zecora 50 cent courtney kemp
anyway i'm not plugging i love it
it's great it's such a good that's close
to you like it's a character though
he's a he's a mismatch of a lot of uh
characters i grew up with and if if i'd
continue continued on a certain road
maybe i'd have been there who knows
haunted underscored john what was it
like preparing for the role of tulk
tulik
preparing for the guardians of the
galaxy two and how much of that was you
i smoked cigarettes with sparkles then
they'd be with me then we screamed in
front of the camera uh so that was your
prep uh yeah james gone we love james we
[__] love james we had big jeff there
steven g
aka jeff
love him you were there [__] love you
so chris sullivan chris big christmas i
saw him there
so anyway yeah there wasn't a lot of
prep for me i mean i got the the
this so it's like [__] everything's
under lock and key i got my dialogue the
night before and then when they sent it
to me i was like i'm [__] doing this
really and i flew down to see james and
jim's like come on you go ahead do it
okay and we figured it out and then then
i turned up one set and i've got my
weird teeth and my dreadlocks and and
did you like that process of getting all
that makeup on or do you not like it i i
didn't mind at that time because uh was
it was it kami who was her name i'm
sorry makeup artist yeah the hair can
you camille was so wonderful i spent a
lot of tickets on dreadlocks and [__]
and she was great and the whole they
were all great in there and i loved it
and yeah
it was nice it was nice i get a little
claustrophobic with prosthetics and
things i don't know what about i don't i
don't like that stuff i you know thank
god i just had to do cgi dots on my face
those those [__] lovely sparkles
that's where the name sparkle comes from
sparkles sparkles are you gonna call me
sparkles from now on ryan
i mean now
steph a stephanie
was it emotionally or mentally draining
being in sons of anarchy it just looks
like a lot of yes you know because this
fictional brotherhood kind of became
this real brotherhood
and
we lived on that [__] set we we rode
our bikes to work in the morning and
then we would
in the evening and then we'd ride their
bicycle
we smoked cigarettes and they would ride
our motorcycles home
yeah we we kind of lived that for for
for seven years so it was yeah a lot of
what you saw up on the screen like i was
saying earlier you have to have that
camaraderie and everyone has to be
treated equal and
then it shows up on the screen i think
that's why a lot of reasons why sons of
archive was successful yeah yeah i
always like to know the crew right away
love some names especially the people
like you know the
everyone's important but the people that
you're interacting with constantly i
want to know their names i have kids you
can't go a month and then go what's your
name you help me every day
it's just [__] wrong
it's your family you see these people
more than you see your family yeah you
know and you mean you don't have to
continue after the show but when you're
there no you're in the [__] duck of
it then get it done and let's get some
love ain't difficult leanne any cool
stories memories from the brave heart we
talked but were there any memories that
you have with mel gibson working with
mel
i remember mtv oh wow what that one just
popped in there
mel was always up to his he always had
tricks going on and pulling gags he's
just that kind of guy just fun fun fun
it's like he just said it light
and the mtv
shows how long ago this [__] was they
were they were interviewing him and i
snuck up behind him and i tied the house
to the interviewer and i tied a piece of
string to the back of his costume and
then i tied it to a trash can full of
dinner plates and [__] and it's just
lunch leftovers then i got around the
front of them and i said mel mal they
need you on set sorry when it cut this
interview and he came running towards me
and the bag was this whole trash can
dragging behind him which he
is back to the mtv but give me the
[__] tape
like swimming with cameras with a tape
was he pissed no no he was loving it
he's a flanagan you can't
to the tape
wow yeah there was a lot of that going
on and i'd say there was so much without
crazy [__] going on really so he was
able to spend a whole hour
is it mind-boggling watching someone
direct such a huge movie act as a lead
role and still be fun and it was
incredible i i mean
the guy
you know the big scene when he rides up
and down slams of scotland would be
dying in your beds and all that big
thing
mel was riding back and crossed back and
forth on the battlefield all day long
giving the english their direction given
the scots i mean thousands of extras did
it
john toll the dp says mel this is your
big thing oh okay
jumps on his horse rides up and down
three takes done
and it's one of the greatest
[__] takes of all time
and the only reason he did three was
because it was a problem with the camera
up up top
but three takes and he's done okay
that's it
and there's a brilliant scene he's all
been doing it all at one wow
i mean there's a couple of close-ups
instead of something but basically that
was it it was incredible i was watching
the whole thing and i was right behind
him when my horse seemed people no
scottish and i was so dumb i didn't
realize that it was a
frame was there so i just see me doing
from there if i hadn't been about smart
like i'm now but i just tell we cut the
steps forward
but whether i know so uh eva h loved you
and uh sons of anarchy uh
pretty much she's saying were you
shocked how bloody the end was
i can't remember it was a boozy end i
don't know i thought what happened it
was a bloody ending was it it was a
really she says ultimately uh
i thought the characters were getting
away comparatively easy for a long time
on the show but were you shocked how
bloody the end was with the characters i
guess oh you mean i don't know okay
people die
[__] i don't know i've never seen them
you don't watch it i've never seen sons
of monarchy you've never seen sons of
anarchy no i i see you did seven seasons
obviously i've saw bets i've never
watched the whole thing i mean i'd go in
the premiere
and because you know because she's just
what you do isn't it
but
but grudgingly i have to ask
because that's what you do because uh
and but i never watched the show
because we were living that like i said
earlier we were living that [__] so
i never really saw
a re i mean i watched for vanity reasons
to see how i was looking because when i
started the show it was a [__] mess
and then i kind of got healthy season
two or three what do you mean you're a
mess uh i just i was in the doldrums for
a minute
just
i didn't know what i was doing next and
uh
my boy john lanson who's the the exec
producer
the original creator of the show
uh you'll see also there's yellowstone
and 1883 with uh what's his name yeah
taylor sheridan so john's a brilliant
brilliant
guy he's one of my dearest dearest
friends my dearest friend and i've known
him 20 plus years he's my daughter's
godfather and anyway john
came to me with sons and and uh
yeah and then
we just did it
but um yeah i don't know i just didn't
watch it it's crazy i mean i i
i understand that i think you know
sometimes if i'm on a series or whatever
i'll watch the first couple kind of you
know see how it's working
and then i'll you know let it go let it
go and that's that's what i did i i'd
every season i'm gonna be cartoon old
okay so i'm looking like that all right
so i'll make that better next season
somebody needs to make a reel
of all your best stuff
and then put it on there because you
probably haven't seen most of it that
you know what i i go on instagram to see
anything i'll see
instagram go whoa that's pretty good i
was like
holy [__] yeah that's not bad oh this is
a treat this is a real treat as for me
for me darling it really is
i mean you just i don't care if you said
and tell the truth often i don't feel
comfortable telling some [__] uh do
you get anxiety
i do yeah
like real anxiety not being nervous
about something but like anxiety where
like you feel like it's taking you off
horrors yeah no
i i stopped smoking weed so that's
diminished quite quickly but
but uh
um
well i've took a pause i took a break
hiatus on the weed yeah but now i still
get i still get very anxious yeah
i try and i mean my wife my daughter and
my wife count me a lot especially my
daughter she keeps me very calm they say
something like this i just heard this
somebody's tell me if i'm wrong they
said when you're with somebody when you
have a significant other that it makes
your stress levels go down yeah is that
true i think maybe i i don't mind
hopefully my child is not absorbing my
stress
horrific
but you know i don't know maybe it's the
love i don't know they calm you just you
just know at the end they
this is this is what your world is all
about it's not about what you're doing
this is your entire universe right here
and so
all the [__] fades away you know you
can
okay
yeah certainly that's crazy kid 10 years
old telling you jokes and
you know and
she'll tell me something stupid you're
getting some silly joke you know tonight
you need to work on that honey
that ain't gonna fly do you have any
good scottish jokes to to end this with
good scott i don't really do jokes
actually i mean billy
the funniest mother i grew up with billy
connelly for christ's sake he's the
funniest man that ever lived and
listened kids if you're out there you
want to hear something hilarious find
billy corny's big banana feet
it's an album from the 1970s and he does
a version of the crucifixion
of jesus and the crucifixion only sets
it in glasgow and it's probably the
funniest every you might need subtitles
but
if you can translate it or hear it i
understand it's the funniest [__]
thing you've ever heard in your life the
crucifixion by billy conley i'll leave
you with that ladies and gentlemen enjoy
it give your ears a treat
tommy flanagan uh this was a pleasure
being inside thank you rosie baby i
loved having you deep inside of me
well well well uh he didn't disappoint
i've been trying to get him on the
podcast since we met on guardians of the
galaxy one
and he did not disappoint yeah did you
have fun while he was in here oh yeah
was it did he pick on you at all uh
no i mean pick on you in a very fun way
very
no it no was uh no like yeah like we
coined shite talking
talking yeah old shite oh yeah
shy talking
remember that song jive talking by the
bee gees jive talking
did it
anyway thank you for listening to the
podcast again if you want to follow the
podcast on
uh
on instagram it's that inside of you
podcast and uh twitter is uh twitter is
that inside you pop pod and study
podcasts on instagram and facebook at
insideyoupod on the twitter and uh you
can also go on youtube please subscribe
live if you liked the show today if you
really enjoyed it you're surprised
you're like you know what rose's mom's
not half bad let's uh let me give him
another chance that would be great i'd
love for you to listen to the podcast
become a patron if you want and all that
stuff uh if you want to join patreon you
could listen to the intro and i talk
about that and i talk about the inside
eat store inside your online store and
thesunspin.com where you can get banned
hats and merch and
zoom me
but right now it's time it's time ryan
i'm excited about talkville by the way
i'm really excited about talkville or we
already have patreons on the um
on on talkville that are supporting that
new podcast and the podcast hasn't even
aired yet it's a fun one it's it's a fun
i'm having fun doing it we've only
recorded a few but just hearing your
perspective yeah on episodes some fresh
perspective
an adult
an adult perspective
and only selling owen wilson there it's
like
someone who hasn't even really watched
the show
and now you're watching it's like really
cool i gotta tell luke about this one
man can i tell luke about this wow
man
it's fun though it's good all right i'm
enjoying it i'm enjoying we'll see we'll
see how it goes it only works if people
listen so hopefully you guys will listen
uh here we go these are the uh
patreon top tiers these are the people
that give back the most to the podcast
and they are worthy very worthy of a
shout out here we go
nancy d leah s sarah v little lisa
yukiko jill e brian h nico p robert b
jason w you know it's funny i could say
all these people's last names even
though it's just initials they give me
yeah bryce gives me here
and i just know that uh you know jason w
i know who that is
it's it's got to be jason weaver it's
dreamweaver
kristen it's got to be kristin kia
anyway i'll stop raj c joshua d cjp
jennifer n stacy l jamal f janelle b
kimberly mike e l don supremo 99 more
ramira santiago m chad w leanne p
janine r maya p maddie s belinda n chris
h dave h sheila g brad d ray h tabitha t
tom n liliana a
betsy
d correct chad l rochelle marion megkay
trav l dan n big stevie w angel amrian
and c cory k super sam dev nixon
michelle a jeremy c andy t cody
uh r correct gavin ate or david c john b
brandy d yvore camille s the c joey l
m oh crap willie f david h design otg
and of course eugene end
uh leah correct chris p
nikki g corey katie b nicole patricia
heather l jake b james b bobbitt megan t
mel s orlando c john b caroline r robbie
paul c christine s sarah s eric h spring
jennifer r shane r emma r
mark m jeremy v who has spoken
andrew m robert g zatoichi 77 andreas n
alexandra and chris r it'd make it easy
if you put all the name with r as the
last initial it'd be easier for you and
then i can go so and so r
r blank r r r
hope if they're all ours too
guys we love having you listen we love
you
um
for supporting this podcast or many
podcasts out there but you choose us at
least as one of your podcasts to listen
to and i know there are a lot of uh
podcasts out there so i thank you from
deep
in the bottom of my heart
and uh
i guess that's it ryan you got anything
else you want to promote something
geez
uh no well why don't you promote the new
podcast that you're on what the talk
bill
what the talk bill
uh
uh yeah the talk phil
it's it's a podcast
about smallville it is it's a podcast
talk about smallville we're excited
about it
uh love you guys be good to yourself um
from the hollywood hills in california i
am michael rosenbaum i'm ryan tez a
little wave to the camera uh we love you
guys seriously be good to yourselves uh
and thank you for allowing me to be
inside of each and every one of you
take care i can't wait for you to hear
the new podcast and let me know what you
think about it all right we'll see
[Music]
you